[Musique]
le voleur s'est introduit par l'une de
ses porte fenêtre laissée ouverte à
l'intérieur ils menacent avec son
pistolet six personnes dont trois agents
de sécurité non armés il s'empare de
plusieurs boîtes de bijoux sautent par
la balustrade laisse tomber quelques
bijoux par terre et s'enfuit à pied sur
la croisette son butin plus de 100
millions d'euros
m
c'est du très grand professionalisme un
vol d'une éclatante simplicité
ils ont déjoué tous les systèmes de
sécurité limités les passes et obturer
les caméras de vidéosurveillance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les papy braqueur descendent alors dans
la cage d'ascenseur il creuse d'un
premier trou puis percer le mur comme
sur ces images de démonstration de
mètres d'épaisseur des heures de travail
on retrouvera sur place une foreuse
diamant
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui tous
je
ils vont tout d'abord si le tube par
lequel l'argent des caisses circulent
avant de plonger à l'intérieur du sas
sécurisés impuissant tuyaux inspirant
pour rafler pièces et billets